but everywhere the natural world is
bursting with backstories the world is
made of or more precisely by time this
is what I mean by time fulness an
awareness of the rich natural history
that envelops us a sense that we to live
in geologic time and are part of a
continuum from the planets past into its
future time fulness is a deliberate
counterpoint to timelessness an
unattainable sterile and I will argue
even dangerous idea but we live in a
time illiterate society as I don't need
to tell this audience we would be
shocked if we an educated adult had no
idea where the continents were on a
global map but don't seem bothered by
the fact that few average people have a
good sense of the geography of the
planets past even though we will spend
our entire lives here we behave like bad
tourists on earth enjoying its amenities
and ransacking its bounty without ever
having noticed that it has its own
ancient language and customs many of the
environmental problems we face have
arisen because we collectively lack a
sense for the duration of chapters in
Earth's history the rates of geologic
processes like groundwater flow or the
intrinsic timescales of natural
phenomena like climate change